[Musique]
le plastique a depuis longtemps envahi
nos modes de vie aujourd'hui encore son
développement est exponentielle pourtant
il s'avère toxique pour notre écosystème
et coupable de perturber notre système
endocrinien telle est l'impaccable
démonstration qui vient de nous livrer
ce documentaire réalisé par Dorothée
Adam sur le plan écologique et de la
santé publique sa production et sa
consommation doivent donc être mis en
cause mais comment faire quels sont les
solutions envisageables pour y parvenir
nous allons en débattre maintenant avec
nos invités présents sur ce plateau en
commençant par vous Philippe bolo
bienvenue et vous êtes députés modem du
Maine-et-Loire et co-rapporteur d'un
rapport parlementaire intitulé pollution
plastique une bombe à retardement alors
il y a pas de points d'interrogation
c'est une affirmation à ce titre de ce
rapport on vous a vu également bien sûr
dans dans ce film témoigner de votre
travail un travail qui aura pris plus
d'un an ce travail parlementaire 139
auditions auprès de tous les acteurs de
la filière concernée et vous avez remis
ce rapport en décembre 2020 rapport
réalisé avec la sénatrice Angèle
Préville la socialiste en gel prévu qui
était aussi bien sûr présente dans ce
film Nathalie Gontard est également avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes directrice de
recherche à l'INRA l'Institut national
de la recherche agronomique bien entendu
à Montpellier et co Autriche avec Hélène
saint-gier de ce livre plastique le
grand emballement publié aux éditions
Stock et puis enfin avec nous Dorothée
Moisan bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
indépendante spécialisée dans les
questions climatiques et
environnementales et auteur de ce livre
intitulé les plastiques et publié aux
éditions Kero alors c'est vrai qu'après
avoir vu ce film qui nous démonte par A
+ B grâce au témoignages scientifique
grâce à des expériences en images la
toxicité du plastique
c'est vrai qu'on se dit que c'est
vraiment le monde à l'envers le
plastique c'est la troisième le
troisième matériau fabriqué dans le
monde après le ciment et l'acier on
apprend dans ce documentaire que sa
production devrait doubler d'ici 2050
triplés d'ici 2060 sa progression est
donc exponentielle et là après avoir vu
ce film on se dit non seulement on va
droit dans le mur mais on y va même en
klaxonnant c'est-à-dire que le
diagnostic est quand même terrible et on
se demande pourquoi autant de retard à
l'allumage pour s'inquiéter de cette
toxicité du plastique quand même
comment on explique ce retard à
l'allumage sans doute parce que la
quantité astronomique de plastique qu'on
produit aujourd'hui n'est pas n'est pas
le fruit d'une longue histoire et qu'au
départ c'était certains usages du
plastique
est réserves à certains usages et qu'au
fur et à mesure de la découverte de ces
fonctionnalités ça légèreté sont prêts
modestes etc et bien il a envahi tous
les comportements de notre vie
quotidienne et on le voit tous les jours
et c'est à partir de ce moment là que
vous avez aussi des phénomènes de de
pollution et cette massification de son
usage pose un certain nombre de
questions qui se posent pas évidemment
au tout début lorsque vous avez que
quelques objets qu'il utilise donc
la prise en compte par le les
responsables politiques de ce problème à
la fois on l'a compris écologique et
aussi un problème de santé publique
aujourd'hui elle est très récente en
réalité votre rapport date de 2020 il
est très complet ce travail que vous
avez réalisé avec votre collègue
sénatrice mais tout cela est très récent
la prise en compte du côté des
responsables politiques vous dire il y a
des choses comme ça oui alors c'est
aussi le fait que les responsables
politiques pour agir sont interpellés
par la société soit par les ONG les
associations qui constatent les
désordres introduits par le plastique
c'est une première chose et puis aussi
les scientifiques le travers des travaux
qui sont les leurs nous alertes et
lorsque tous ces signaux faibles
commencent à se mastiffer que vous venez
de citer les ONG les scientifiques
interviennent poussent sur ces questions
pour que le responsable politique
finalement ne s'empare du et la société
devient aussi nature pour dire oui on a
un problème et qu'il faut résoudre et
quand tout le monde est parti dans ce
sens là après il est évident qu'il faut
trouver des solutions je m'adresse à la
scientifique alors maintenant parce que
bon c'est vrai qu'on constate dans ce
film c'est assez récent toutes ces
découvertes concernant la toxicité du
plastique c'est vraiment le cas
oui enfin disons que pour répondre
peut-être à cette question de retard à
l'allumage je voudrais dire que ce qui
est important de comprendre c'est que le
plastique a un comportement complètement
différent de tous les autres matériaux
que l'homme a utilisé jusqu'à présent et
qu'il utilise
et qu'on a pas anticipé ce comportement
c'est à dire qu'on ne s'en est pas méfié
on ne l'a pas étudié et alors c'est quoi
ce comportement se comportement et que
le plastique va persister très longtemps
dans notre environnement et dans nos
corps après s'être fragmenté en micro et
en unoplastique et qu'en plus il va être
capable de Sorber mais ça ça arrive en
plus il n'y a aucun autre matériau sur
terre qui se comporte comme ça le papier
le carton le coton la laine le bois toi
ce sont des matériaux qui se
biodégradent c'est à dire que notre
écosystème a les outils biologiques pour
pouvoir le digérer et ensuite
reconstituer une matière donc ce sont
des matériaux qui ne pourront jamais
s'accumuler sur notre terre pendant des
centaines voire des milliers d'années
comme le plastique les autres matériaux
comme le métal ou le vert vont pouvoir
persister longtemps mais ne se fragmente
pas et ce sont des matériaux qui sont
inertes c'est à dire qu'ils ne peuvent
pas donc Sorber et ils ne peuvent pas
non plus voyager donc du coup le risque
majeur le danger c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très particulier et ça je crois
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à le comprendre
parce que très souvent on considère que
les déchets tous les déchets sont
équivalents non non le plastique est un
matériau à part est un déchet
particulièrement dangereux parce que
c'est un
héritage que l'on va donner aux
générations futures alors on a des
risques là aujourd'hui avec des
migrations de perturbateurs endocriniens
par exemple avec des micro
nanoplastiques on retrouve déjà dans nos
organismes mais le gros de ces dangers
ce sont aux générations à venir qu'on
l'élève et c'est là où on a beaucoup de
mal je crois à accepter ce fait là et à
le réaliser et à se dire c'est
maintenant qu'il faut agir parce
qu'ensuite c'est trop tard
ce retard à l'allumage est-ce qu'il faut
pas mettre cela sur le compte d'une
industrie hyperpuissante hyper puissante
sur le plan économique je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure un troisième matériau fabriqué
au monde le plastique effectivement
retard allumage sur la prise en compte
par les politiques aujourd'hui par le
fait qu'on commence en parler dans la
sphère politique mais c'est pas c'est
pas nouveau que le plastique et toxique
puisque alors il y a première question
la pollution plastique dès les années 80
aux États-Unis on avait des
manifestations monstres avec tous ces
déchets plastiques qui s'accumulaient
autour des villes parce que les
fast-food etc les McDonald's et autres
ou est-ce qu'on mettait tout ça c'était
à l'entrée des villes et il y avait des
projets de loi aux Etats-Unis qui
projetaient d'interdire les les
applicateurs pour les tampons et les
couches-culottes et ça on pourrait même
pas imaginer ça aujourd'hui parce que
tout ça c'est du plastique et donc il y
avait vraiment des alertes qui ont été
donnés dès cette époque-là pour la
toxicité les perturbateurs endocriniens
Nathalie pourrait donc confirmer mais il
y a une trentaine d'années ça a vraiment
été mis sur le devant de la scène on a
compris leur fonctionnement et on a
compris que la plupart des
dans le plastique qu'on utilisait tous
les jours il y a une trentaine d'années
mais en fait ça veut dire que tout le
monde est l'industrie du plastique la
première était consciente de ces
difficultés de ses problèmes de toxicité
depuis bien longtemps le problème c'est
que au grand public ces années c'est ce
qui expliquerait qu'on est au temps de
retard pour la revient toujours à la
charge de la preuve qui va revenir aux
scientifiques ou qui va revenir aux
autorités mais tout seul est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment prouver qu'on
est au courant ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est ce qui se passe avec
l'industrie moi c'est ce que j'ai
l'enquête que j'ai mené dans les
plastiquesurs c'était vraiment je
compare un peu le plastique à ce qui
s'est passé avec avec le tabac ou
l'amiante prenons le tabac on découvre
dans les années 50 enfin l'industrie
découvre dans les années 50 que le tabac
provoque du cancer du poumon que
tabagisme passif etc ont des impacts sur
la santé humaine il faudra attendre les
années 1990 et les premiers cancers sur
le tabac pour que avec des procédures
américaines qui imposent aux entreprises
de révéler les documents en interne
qu'on découvre qu'effectivement le tabac
et enfin que l'industrie savait depuis
40 ans que le tabac provoquait le cancer
du poumon et là on a 100 millions de
morts au XXe siècle à cause du tabac
autrement dit depuis quand l'industrie
du plastique on va généraliser et au
courant des perturbations du système
endocrinien par exemple possible grâce à
ce matériau s'il vous plaît
énorme et fantastique mais en tout cas
je pense que depuis très clairement
alors le PVC parce que du PVC ça fait
bien longtemps ça fait au milieu du 20e
siècle mais pour d'autres plastiques je
pense qu'on peut dire que c'est vraiment
les années 90 on peut pas avoir de doute
sur certains plastiques dès les années
90 le bisphénol A dont on entend
beaucoup parler les salades dans les
années 90 qu'on découvre leur toxicité
pour notamment l'organisme humain et
donc on va l'interdire on va commencer
interdire le bisphénol dans les biberons
notamment dans les pays occidentaux au
début des années 2000 vous voulez
rajouter quelque chose oui ce que je
voulais dire c'est que c'est tout à fait
c'est à peu près une bonne vingtaine
d'années qu'on a découvert l'effet des
additifs que donc l'obscatif pouvait
migrer donc des lois ont été prises
quand même pour les pour les limiter
c'est loin on peut être prise sur la
base de connaissances qui étaient
quantifié lorsqu'on s'adresse à au
danger principal du plastique qui
concerne les particules de plastique
c'est tellement complexe parce que on
parle du plastique mais il y a des
milliers le plastique contient tellement
d'additifs il a une histoire qui peut
être tellement variée que infini ce que
l'on n'arrive pas à faire actuellement
même si on multiplie les connaissances
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire c'est à
quantifier c'est-à-dire à mettre un
chiffre sur les impacts de ces
plastiques parce que ces impacts sont
complexes et parce qu'ils vont arriver
très longtemps après la production de
ces plastiques donc le résultat c'est
qu'on base la plupart des stratégies sur
des analyses de cycle de vie qui
évoquent les aspects de bilan carbone or
le plastique on n'est pas sur des bilans
carbone on est sur le problème ce sont
des empreintes plastiques des empreintes
de particules de plastique et c'est bien
différent et c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
lancé dans tout un tas de stratégies au
niveau de l'Europe au niveau national
dont le recyclage qui sont basés sur des
bilans carbone alors le recyclage on va
en parler j'en profite tout de même pour
citer le top 5
des entreprises qui génèrent le plus de
pollution plastique dans le monde numéro
1 Coca-Cola
PepsiCo numéro 2 Unilever numéro 3
Nestlé numéro 4 propreteur et humble
numéro 5 il y a tout de même une
industrie française et une entreprise
française concernée qui arrive en 8e
position et qui est Danone on verra
peut-être si ces entreprises ont fait
des efforts pour pour diminuer la
toxicité de du plastique en tout cas
voilà les entreprises qui polluent le
plus en matière de plastique au monde
somme le plus mauvaise élève européens
en matière de recyclage du plastique
nous ne recyclons que 28% du plastique
consommé en France et d'ailleurs sont
conseillé dans ce film c'est votre
collègue qui le conseille de à tout le
monde d'aller dans un centre de tri un
de recyclage pour se rendre compte de la
réalité des choses en matière de
recyclage notamment concernant le le
plastique pourquoi est-ce qu'on est le
plus mauvais élève en Europe concernant
le recyclage du plastique
ça c'est une question une veste question
je crois qu'il faut aussi se poser la
question parce que on parle souvent du
recyclage
en faisant un concert en disant est-ce
qu'on est les meilleurs ou pas les les
plus mauvais là on est plus mauvais en
Europe ok donc ce qu'il voudrait dire
que finalement si on était parmi les
meilleurs et que tout le monde n'était
parmi les meilleurs on aurait trouvé la
solution plastique grâce au recyclage
c'est pas exactement le sujet c'est à
dire qu'effectivement il y a un constat
qui est qu'on n'est pas les meilleurs
parmi recyclage ne n'oublions jamais
qu'avant le recyclage on a aussi la
réduction la consommation de plastique
le réemploi des plastiques le recyclage
étant une voix une solution qui arrive
en troisième position mais c'est pas la
solution ultime c'est à dire qu'on
définitive pour moi le recyclage c'est
juste un amortisseur temporel c'est à
dire que parce que pour une simple et
bonne raison qu'il ne faut jamais
oublier c'est que nos plastiques à la
différence du vert à la différence de
l'aluminium ils ont un cycle nombre de
cycles de recyclage possible au-delà de
lesquels sans rentrer dans les détails
de chimique et de la physique ils
perdent leur propriété donc ça veut dire
qu'on peut certains les recycler cette
fois d'autres deux fois et qu'en
définitive même si on était parfait ça
veut dire qu'au lieu d'avoir le déchet
tout de suite après l'utilisation d'un
produit qui peut durer 10 jours et
d'autres produits qui vont durer
plusieurs années on va le recycler à
nouveau donc on va reparti sur 10 jours
ou dix années mais à partir d'un certain
moment on arrive quand même à un déchets
et donc finalement au lieu d'avoir le
déchet immédiatement ingéré on aura plus
tard comme Madame gomter disait qu'on
l'AG au générations futures ce problème
du plastique avec le recyclage on
temporise un peu l'héritage mais on ne
le résout pas c'est pour ça que je
disais qu'à certains de personnes
devaient tomber de haut parce que le
recyclage ça passe par évidemment la
fameuse poubelle jaune je suis très
pragmatique effectivement les déchets
plastiques aujourd'hui il faut les
mettre autant que possible dans cette
fameuse poubelle jaune en espérant un
recyclage est-ce que vous nous dites là
ce qui est dit aussi dans le film c'est
que c'est pas le la solution
ultime pour ce pour limiter les la
toxicités du premier champ juste pour
revenir sur les chiffres différents les
28% dont vous parlez on parle que des
emballages plastiques attention parce
qu'il y a pas que en plastique on a
aussi le plastique dans le bâtiment dans
l'automobile où on a à peu près 20% du
plastique qui recyclé aujourd'hui en
France 80% qui ne l'est pas et là on est
sur des des masques qui n'ont rien à
voir c'est énorme donc première chose
ensuite au niveau européen il y a eu il
y a 2 ans à peu près un rapport de
l'Union européenne qui montrait fin de
la Cour des comptes qui montrait que
d'un pays à l'autre chacun calculé à sa
façon à la façon de tirer aussi qu'elle
plastique qu'est-ce qu'on ressenti pas
donc ces chiffres là sont vraiment à
prendre avec énormément de précautions
en plus il y a aussi une partie de ce
recyclage que par exemple pour les
emballages plastiques si Théo qui est en
fait l'industrie qui gère tout ça va
dire bah nous on a vendu un régénérateur
entendre un recycleur lui il dit moi
j'achète du polystyrène où j'achète du
PET promis je le recycle mais après si
Théo ne va pas voir ce qui se passe
derrière donc on nous assure que oui
c'est recyclé sauf qu'après on retrouve
des emballages plastiques français en
Turquie c'est que a priori il y a une
maille dans le filet donc ces chiffres
de 28 30% je prends un autre exemple
l'Allemagne en Allemagne en nous disait
pendant longtemps 66% du plastique et
recyclé Greenpeace une étude en fait il
y en avait beaucoup recyclés c'est aussi
incinéré en fait non c'est pas
l'incinération n'est pas du recyclage
l'Allemagne conteste qui était utilisé
pour incinérer et donc revaloriser comme
du recyclage en fait on était à des
chiffres plus proches de 34 %. donc
vraiment se méfier des chiffres ensuite
pour la poubelle jaune c'est simple il
faut pas arriver à la poubelle jaune si
on n'a pas le choix et qu'on a avec son
emballage bon on a une poubelle jaune
devant soi on le jette devant la
poubelle jaune mais le but aujourd'hui
c'est de ne pas arriver à la poubelle
jaune autrement dit de réduire la
production de réduire de choses nous la
consommation l'achat quand on va au
supermarché ou ailleurs de réduire un
maximum et de réduire de plafonner la
production mais c'est pas ce que
comprenne aujourd'hui législateur
puisque moi j'habite en Bretagne on a
multiplié par deux le passage de mes
poubelles jaunes donc j'ai une
incitation à mettre dans la poubelle
jaune
c'est faire comprendre aux consommateurs
je préfère appeler les particuliers aux
particuliers que mettre dans la poubelle
jaune c'est bien alors que c'est pas ça
puisqu'effectivement le recyclage ne
fonctionne pas ou clairement pas à long
de ce qu'on nous promet donc il faut ne
pas arriver là et ne pas inciter les
consommateurs à remplir un rapport leur
poubelles jaunes il faut d'abord ne pas
acheter de plastique Nathalie Gontard
j'ai relevé une phrase que vous avez
prononcé dans le magazine reporter
l'économie circulaire en matière de
plastique est un mythe disiez vous je
parlerai plutôt d'économie tire-bouchon
on ne ferme jamais la boucle on la
prolonge indéfiniment voilà ce que vous
pensez du recyclage humidité pour le
réemploi pour le ré en partie et d'abord
en priorité la réduction donc peut-être
pour revenir sur ce que
sur ce que mes collègues viennent de
dire ce qu'on appelle recyclage en
réalité n'en est pas c'est à dire c'est
du recyclage donc que vous nous avez
expliqué c'est que finalement c'est
mieux que rien ça permet de reporter
l'état de déchet puisque quelque part ça
nous rassure ce déchet plastique devient
utile mais non moi je dis non c'est pire
que rien c'est pire que rien parce qu'on
construit des filières entières on
cherche de nouveaux débouchés donc on
construit des filières entières
d'utilisation de recyclage ce qui veut
dire qu'on fait disparaître des filières
par exemple de pull en laine ou en coton
qui ne posaient pas autant de problèmes
environnementaux ensuite ces usines à
gaz une fois qu'on les a construits il
faut les alimenter en déchets donc
plastique donc ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir continuer en produire et surtout
surtout on ne résout absolument pas le
problème de la pollution la preuve en
est c'est que les pays les plus vertueux
en termes de recyclage par exemple
l'Allemagne ou l'Autriche ou les
Pays-Bas qui recyclent jusqu'à 50% de
leur production plastique n'ont même pas
commencé à diminuer leur consommation de
plastique vierge non mais je sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte alors que
normalement 50% de réduction on aurait
dû diviser par deux la consommation de
plastiques vierge or non c'est payant
continuent en utiliser de plus en plus
donc on produit toujours de des plus de
déchets et en plus on s'enfer dans une
dans une situation où lorsqu'on
s'apercevra de notre erreur c'est-à-dire
que ce n'est pas du recyclage que l'on
fait c'est du des cyclage on ne pourra
plus revenir en arrière voilà pourquoi
je parle d'économie tire-bouchon c'est à
dire que vraiment on s'enfonce pour
rebondir sur ce que dit Nathalie il y a
une étude qui a été menée en 2017 aux
États-Unis pour montrer que les gens
quand ils voyaient écrire aussi
recyclables sur le paquet de riz etc
super ils avaient tendance à en acheter
plus parce qu'ils avaient l'impression
qu'ils allaient sauver la planète en
gros qu'ils allaient faire un bon geste
pour l'environnement et donc ils ont
démontré que l'émotion positive créée
par leur recyclage des passait l'émotion
négative du gaspillage et donc ça
explique un petit peu ce que disait
Nathalie gonta tout à l'heure c'est
qu'effectivement on va pas réduire la
consommation de plastique à ce moment-là
on va au contraire l'affaire grossir la
solution la piste du réemploi une des
pistes impatience on a bien compris que
ça sera pas une piste unique
probablement dans le sujet que tu nous
concerne aujourd'hui pour réduire la
production la consommation et la
toxicité et donc du du plastique le
réemploi c'est possible oui c'est
possible et à quelles conditions écoutez
je crois que les nos grands-parents
faisaient beaucoup plus de réemploi que
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui utiliser
beaucoup moins de contenants en
plastique on voit avec le la vente en
vrac le commerce en vrac des solutions
de réemploi il y a eu le sujet de la
consigne c'est aussi d'une certaine
façon un peu un sujet de réemploi donc
oui c'est des choses qui arrivent alors
ce que moi je la consigne sur les
bouteilles plastiques ça peut ça
pourrait exister alors
elle a été poussée parce que finalement
vous savez nos bouteilles plastique sont
dans un polymère qui est le plus
facilement recyclable
mécaniquement et qui permet vraiment
dans le sens de ce que disait madame
Gontard de refaire une bouteille à
partir d'une bouteille toujours ajouter
un petit peu de polymère vierge parce
que sinon elle perd un peu en propriété
peu importe donc ça peut ça peut exister
sur les bouteilles le réemploi je vous
dis nos ancêtres nos grands-parents le
faisaient ce que je crois surtout et qui
est important à comprendre c'est que
finalement le plastique il a introduit
dans nos dans nos vies une sorte de
confort ce que leur emploi ça veut dire
que c'est un peu plus contraignant que
l'emballage a usage unique vous prenez
que vous ouvrez quand vous avez fait ce
que vous avez à faire avec vous le
mettez à la corbeille le emploi je
prends mon contenant je mets à
l'intérieur ce que j'ai besoin d'y
mettre je le nettoie à la fin et il fait
son cycle plusieurs fois et donc
finalement avec le plastique on a allégé
nos charges de travail ménagère par
exemple et finalement quand vous avez
donné à quelqu'un la possibilité
d'aménager sa charge de travail et que
vous lui libérez du temps pour faire
autre chose qui est plus agréable que
d'aller faire de la lessive de la
vaisselle de l'entretien vérifier qu'on
a dans le frigo les bons aliments qui
vont pas se périmer dans la semaine et
il va falloir nourrir la famille avec ce
temps-là vous le gardez pour vous et
vous avez une difficulté à revenir en
arrière c'est pour ça qu'on a aussi des
consommateurs aujourd'hui qui ont été
emprisonnés pris au piège de ce système
de l'emballage plastique à usage unique
parce que c'est ça aussi qu'il faut
qu'il faut viser et qui parce qu'elle
aura apporté du confort aujourd'hui ils
ont du mal à revenir en arrière en se
disant il faudrait que du réemploi avec
un contenant en verre qui va me donner
des charges alors c'est vrai que dans le
viseur y compris du législateur en tout
cas du législateur français c'est ce
fameux en plastique à emploi unique et
qui en priorité dans le viseur c'est
cela qu'on interdit en premier ça a
commencé d'ailleurs avec les sacs à
usage avec
usage unique et aujourd'hui ça va
jusqu'au paille je veux pas évidemment
décliner tous les produits en qui était
en plastique qu'on essaie de substituer
alors avec du bambou avec d'autres
matières la substitution au plastique
c'est un c'est un sujet c'est une piste
à envisager est-ce qu'elle est joie
parce que est-ce qu'elle aussi elle est
pas anti-écologique un certain moment
cette solution des substituts disons que
moi je pense que c'est une solution
c'est clair c'est pas la c'est pas la
principale je pense qu'il faut qu'on
change nos modes de consommation et
surtout les quantités que l'on consomme
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut que l'on
vive on apprenne à vivre autrement après
ça peut être une solution par exemple là
on vient de parler du réemploi c'est
vrai que le plastique est un matériau
qui n'est pas conçu pour être réemployé
parce que ce n'est pas un matériau
inerte comme le métal le verre par
exemple c'est un matériau qui va Sorber
qui va s'abîmer donc il est difficile de
le réemployer de nombreuses fois sans
prendre des risques sans faire prendre
des risques aux personnes qui l'auraient
emploient donc c'est très compliqué
ensuite il y a d'autres matériaux qui
sont difficiles à employables justement
aussi comme par exemple le papier le
carton mais là c'est pas très grave
puisque notre écosystème absorbera tout
ça donc c'est vrai qu'il faut trouver
des matériaux en fait quelque part
toutes les substitutions sont bonnes au
plastique à partir du moment où on
n'utilise pas du plastique c'est-à-dire
un matériau qui aura ce comportement
très particulier alors toutes les
substitutions sont bonnes vous êtes
d'accord avec ça tant qu'elle ne sont
pas jetables en fait le but est de
sortir du jetable en fait c'est pas tant
de sortir du plastique qui est un
matériau
on peut dire diabolique allons-y parce
que pour avoir vraiment étudié la
question le plus je peux me passer de
plastique aujourd'hui le plus je le
ferai donc pour passer un autre matériau
mais ça veut dire que l'autre matériau
ça veut dire que c'est quelque chose
qu'on va réutiliser donc admettons alors
c'est là que
naturel qu'est-ce qu'on appelle
naturelle un problème environnemental
prenons par exemple tout simplement la
bouteille d'eau puisque aujourd'hui les
bouteilles d'eau enfin les bouteilles
d'eau la bouteille on peut notamment
l'eau qui continue à être produite etc
vous voyez ça en plastique en disant oui
maintenant c'est fini plus 11 % de
production d'ici 2027 de sacs plastiques
donc c'est pas du tout fini les sacs en
plastique on en produit 10 millions
chaque minute aujourd'hui donc je sais
pas combien depuis le début de cette
émission on a produit de sacs plastiques
si on en revient au début de cette
émission on marche tout de même un peu
sur la tête et donc par exemple prenons
la bouteille d'eau on leur remplace par
exemple par une gourde en verre en inox
c'est là que vous avez toute l'industrie
qui va vous dire ah ben oui mais si on
fait le bilan carbone etc de l'inox ou
du vert c'est énorme par rapport à la
bouteille en plastique certes mais notre
gourde en inox ou notre Gourdon vert on
va pas l'acheter après utilisation on va
la garder la gourde en inox L1 l'intérêt
si on la garde 10 ans et là
effectivement elle a un vrai intérêt on
est tous à poil j'aime bien cette
expression
formuler avec ce témoin dans dans ce
film et pourtant vous dites attention
attention il s'agit pas de tomber dans
le plastique bashing alors ça j'aimerais
bien que vous nous l'expliquiez écoutez
c'est simple tous les plastiques ne sont
pas égaux est-ce qu'on est prêt à se
passer aujourd'hui de nos verres de
lunettes nous sommes la moitié à
emporter est-ce qu'on est prêt
aujourd'hui à se placer à se passer des
plastiques qui sont utilisés dans les
salles d'opération des hôpitaux est-ce
que nous sommes prêts à nous passer des
plastiques qui isole les fils
électriques de nos maisons il y a des
usages du plastique qui ne posent pas de
problème de mon point de vue les
plastiques posent problème c'est ceux
qu'on va retrouver dans la nature alors
qu'est-ce qu'on va retrouver dans Nature
soit les granulés qui servent à faire
les plastiques d'origine c'est une
première fuite soit nos vêtements
lorsqu'ils sont dans des matériaux
synthétiques chaque cycle de lavage une
série de micro ainsi qu'une quantité qui
va partir dans les eaux qu'on va
retrouver sur les sols dans les rivières
et dans les océans c'est l'usure de nos
pneuma des pneumatiques de nos voitures
sur les routes et puis c'est aussi toute
une série de soit de mauvais
comportement soit de d'absence de
système de traitement qui fait qu'en fin
de vie on a un certain nombre d'objets
qu'on va retrouver dans la nature et qui
vont comme l'a dit Madame Gontard et
bien se dégrader être soumise au soleil
à l'eau il faudrait on peut on pourrait
commencer peut-être par un tri sans les
différents typologies de plastique
existantes différentes technologies
amenant à produire ce plastique il faut
être savoir faire la différence entre
des plastiques utiles irremplaçable et
qui ne pose pas de problème
environnementaux des plastiques
accessoires remplaçables et qui pose des
problèmes environnementaux
et pour compléter je dirais que c'est la
dose qui fait le poison et que nos
organismes comme notre écosystème est
capable de supporter une certaine dose
de plastique le problème c'est que là on
est allé bien au-delà de ce que nous
allons pouvoir supporter que on a
vraiment on consomme des quantités de
plastique énorme donc c'est évident
qu'il faut réduire notre consommation
plastique de façon drastique au
plastique qui nous sont indispensables
essentiels et c'est là où je trouve
qu'il y a un débat qui va s'ouvrir et
qui va être très riche d'enseignements
parce qu'on va sortir de nos solutions
technocentrées ou matériels centrés où
on va chercher justement seulement un
matériel de substitution or le plastique
il est tellement partout il sert
tellement à plein plein de fonctions
différentes qu'on va vraiment se poser
on va devoir se poser des questions sur
nos modes de vie et je pense que c'est
là où on parle beaucoup de la fin de
l'abandon
et
c'est une des composantes aussi un peu
ce que je voulais
actuellement on parle beaucoup de la fin
d'abondance on pourrait parler de la fin
de l'abondance pour le pour le plastique
moi je pense que non au contraire il y a
beaucoup d'abondance qu'on n'a pas
encore exploré d'État d'abondance qui
vont pouvoir remplacer ces matériaux
plastiques que l'on met un petit peu à
toutes les sauces actuellement lorsqu'on
va dans un supermarché outre donc de
sport de plein air enlever les
plastiques il n'y a plus rien comme si
on ne pouvait plus avoir du plaisir en
plein air sans être couvert de plastique
de la tête aux pieds de matériaux
plastique donc ce que vous partagez
cette analyse ou est-ce que d'une
certaine manière vous êtes plus radical
vous a senti très très partisane de
s'arrêter cette production d'arriver à
l'arrêté je pense qu'il faudrait radical
parce que c'est pas c'est bien gentil le
plastique bashing je suis d'accord ça
peut ça peut aller contre les faits sauf
que ça fait aujourd'hui 70 ans que
l'industrie qui
je pense que tout le monde le voit c'est
notamment l'industrie pétrochimique
l'industrie du plastique il faut le
savoir ce sont les mêmes est extrêmement
puis et depuis 70 ans
convaincre tout le monde que le
plastique est fantastique et que surtout
le plastique et non toxique depuis
quelques temps avant c'était juste
fantastique maintenant c'est aussi non
toxique ils ont une puissance de feu et
c'est une industrie qui est énormément
d'argent aujourd'hui il faut vraiment
aller dans le sens inverse il faut
vraiment expliquer à quel point le
plastique il faut s'en passer alors bien
sûr qu'on pourra pas se passer du
plastique dans les éoliennes dans les
panneaux photovoltaïques à l'hôpital je
suis un petit peu moins d'accord par
exemple ça dépend des usages de
l'hôpital c'est beaucoup l'usage
effectivement l'usage unique même à
l'hôpital c'est à dire que il y a dans
une salle d'opération il y a quelques
années encore il y a 10 20 ans on avait
ouais même 20-30 ans encore 20 ans on
avait tout un set d'ustensile de
stérilisé après une opération
chirurgicale aujourd'hui c'est remplacé
par par une petite pochette en plastique
à usage unique qui a peut-être il y a
plusieurs
ustensiles dedans on l'ouvre on en prend
un seul on jette l'ensemble voilà donc
ça c'est des exemples tout simple à
l'hôpital on peut vraiment changer il
faut savoir que le plastique est plus
présent à l'hôpital c'est le PVC 40% du
plastique présent à l'hôpital c'est le
PVC vous savez qu'on a un petit peu
partout dans énormément de choses et le
PVC c'est celui qui va émettre des COV
des composés organiques volatils durant
toute sa durée de vie donc des petites
choses qui vont vous rentrer dans les
narines qui sont mauvaises pour vous à
l'hôpital dans un milieu où les êtres
les plus vulnérables donc les personnes
malades les enfants les bébés sont
présents donc il y a vraiment des choses
à faire qui sont effectivement
drastiques et qui sont pas si compliqué
qu'on peut nous le fait le croire
maintenant effectivement c'est pas
évident mais surtout si on revient à des
choses réutilisables et c'est pas de
revenir à la bougie etc ce qu'on va bien
sûr entendre du côté de l'industrie
c'est revenir à la simplicité et elle a
raison alors justement je rebondirai sur
vos propos qui sont de mon point de vue
une nouvelle démonstration de du confort
qu'apporte le plastique je reprends
votre équipe médicale qui fait une
opération il y a 20 ans de cela elle
avait un certain nombre de d'équipements
quelle stérilisés avant l'opération
aujourd'hui on ouvre une pochette
plastique on prend le scalpel à
l'intérieur le bistouri ce que vous
voulez et on fait l'opération elle a
fait en jette mais
c'est aussi compréhensible que dans
cette équipe médicale les moyens humains
soient utilisés pour soigner le patient
pour lui être le plus
utile possible et qu'on évite le temps
passé par exemple pour les stérilisation
vous voyez ce que je veux dire à partir
du moment où vous avez mis entre les
mains des personnes quelque chose qui
est qui leur évite l'acte de
stérilisation qui prend du temps et qui
doit être fait mener de manière très
rigoureuse parce que sinon on va sur un
problème de mais vous savez aussi que
les hôpitaux des problèmes de coups et
aujourd'hui on réalise que d'acheter
finalement c'est sûr que d'avoir une
stérilisation ça avait un coup il
fallait stériliser c'est c'est ces
outils en acier sauf qu'aujourd'hui on
en revient parce qu'on va effectivement
acheter à chaque fois ça coûte pas cher
one shot quand on va acheter eux sur un
an tous ces produits c'est sur blues
qu'on a dans ton a parlé c'est masque
hein parce qu'avant c'est des masques en
tissu qui était très efficace les
dernières études des années 70 montrait
que les masques en tissu filtrer mieux
toutes ces microbes et les bactéries que
les masques en plastique
donc je vais dire plutôt l'inverse ce
temps gagné en jetant des objets il faut
savoir quand même qu'on va le perdre par
ailleurs en les fabricant et que
maintenant on est quand même tous en
train de constater que la gestion des
déchets derrière nous coûte énormément
et il finit c'est du temps qui est gagné
c'est vrai qu'on peut le voir comme ça
mais il est perdu ailleurs donc ce sont
des choix de vie qui va falloir faire
peut-être des métiers à réinventer à
inventer et à réinventer je suis tout à
fait le débat sur ce sujet là montre
aussi la complexité du sujet c'est
finalement pas si simple que ça de
prendre un bout du sujet de se dire on a
trouvé la solution tout à fait et je
pense qu'il faut que chaque secteur
c'est à dire tous les secteurs de notre
société s'empare de la question et se
pose la question de cette réduction de
l'usage du plastique parce que pour
chaque secteur on va avoir des
contraintes et des solutions différentes
alors l'exemple typique c'est vrai que
c'est les hôpitaux on pourrait dire
après tous les hôpitaux tout leur est
permis mais mais non moi j'ai eu des tas
de de contact avec des médecins qui s'en
plaignent pour eux c'est terrible de
travailler dans ces conditions là en
utilisant en plastique donc je pense que
tous les secteurs industriel doivent
s'emparer de cette question ce sera le
mot de la fin vraiment un grand merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat doc aujourd'hui consacré au
plastique aux conséquences de sa
production pour l'environnement et notre
santé publique vos réactions ça sera
bien sûr sur hashtag des Badoc sur
Twitter j'imagine qu'il y aura beaucoup
de réactions et je compte sur vous pour
réagir à ce que seront bien entendu ces
réactions sur Twitter à cette adresse
merci à Selma Sally qui comme à la
coutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission je vous dis tout simplement à
bientôt avec un autre débat doc qui sera
avec bien entendu son documentaire et
son débat à bientôt
[Musique]